heute spielen wir bei uns im haushalt
ist janisch für das spielen
verantwortlich
ich finde wir haben das sehr gut
geregelt
das heißt nachdem es die stelle ich
einfach mein dreckiges geschirr in die
spüle und später ist es auf magische
weise wieder sauber auf deutsch nennt
man das die spüle
das werk heißt spülen
ich spiele in der spüle
man kann auch ein nomen aus dem werk
bilden janisch liebt das spülen
wir haben keine spülmaschine deshalb
spülen wir alles per hand
das hier ist das dreckige geschirr
es muss gespült werden janisch ist ein
spiel meister er spült morgens und
abends zum spielen benutzt man einen
schwamm und spülmittel
man kann spülmittel auch spüli nennen
janosch warum machst du spülen
schon als kind musste ich zu hause
spülen und seitdem mag ich es auch das
war schon immer meine aufgabe im haus
spülen und den müll wegbringen und was
magst du nicht am spülen
ich mag nicht wenn die sachen in der
spüle abstellt und sie an trocknen lässt
manche dinge muss man vorher
einweichen lassen sonst sind sie später
sehr schwierig zu spielen
vergiss das immer nicht immer nur
manchmal immer das war ihr german beim
spülen
jetzt lassen wir das geschirr abtrocknen
und hoffen auf eure unterstützung bei
petrol wenn ihr ein päckchen von easyjet
werdet helft ihr uns dabei jede woche
videos für euch zu drehen
und hier könnt ihr sie german abonnieren
das solltet ihr machen um immer eine
benachrichtigung über unsere neuesten
videos zu bekommen
tschüss und bis zur nächsten woche